[موسيقى]
مواجهه وشيكا ساحتها رقميه واسلحتها
خوارزميات هائله تلك هي الحروب العصريه
التي يصبح اغلى ما فيها المعلومات المشفره
انها المعركه القادمه بين عصفور ازرق يدعى
تويتر وشركه البرمجيه العملاقه مايكروسوفت
فتيلها اشتعل منذ ان غرد الملياردير
الامريكي ايلون ماسك قائلا انهم يستخدمون
بيانات تويتر بشكل غير قانوني وحان وقت
رفع الدعوه القضائيه وفي رساله تحذيريه
حملت ادعاءات غامضه وجهها اليكسسبيرو
محامي ملكه تويتر الى الساتيا ناديلا
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه مايكروسوفت تتمحور
حول تجاوز حجم الطلب المعقول لبيانات
تويتر بل حتى استخدامها بافراط واساءه
مضيفا ان الاتفاقيه التي عقدت بينهما
لتشرع هذا الكم الهائل من الاستخدام علما
بانهم استرجعوا اكثر من 26 مليار تغريده
في عام 2022 وحده هذا عدا عن ان الاتفاقيه
بينهما نصت على انه لا يحق لميكروسوفت
استرداد ايا من بيانات تويتر لاي كيال او
وكاله دون اخطارهم مطالبا بالتدقيق المفصل
والممل للبيانات التي اخذتها من تويتر او
دمرتها ولاي تطبيق قدمتها ولماذا في
المقابل اكتفى المتحدث باسم مايكروسوفت
فرانك شو بان الشركه ستاخذ بالاعتبار
اسئله وطلبات تويتر
وسترد عليها بالشكل المناسب مؤكدا انهم
يتطلعون الى شراكه طويله الامد اسراء
الصغير العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات